alessio mio figlio a 11 anni ha giocato
per cinque anni a basket poi quest'anno
ha deciso di cambiare sport ha deciso di
iscriversi a pallanuoto ora pallanuoto
non è proprio uno degli sport più
immediati e quindi quando ha preso
questa decisione mi sono chiesta quando
avrebbe giocato la sua prima partita la
realtà ha battuto le mie previsioni
perché ha già giocato un amichevole
domani giocherà la sua prima partita di
campionato
questo è il video di una allenamento
quello che vedete sul fondo con la palla
in mano è alessio che guarda i compagni
e non sa cosa fare poi il l'aiuto
allenatore si abbassa lo incita gli fa
vedere il corridoio che ha davanti a sé
alessio reagisce d'istinto prende la
palla nota va verso la porta e tira
tornando indietro l'allenatore lo si
congratula con lui allora ci sono due
momenti fondamentali in questo video che
hanno cambiato quello che alessio ha
fatto di quella palla e quello che
alessio farà nelle partite future
il primo momento e quando l'aiuto
allenatore si accorge della sua
indecisione e decide di intervenire
mostrandogli il corridoio che ha davanti
e lo incita ad andare verso la porta e
gli grida tira il secondo momento invece
è quando l'aiuto allenatore si abbassa
verso la vasca e batte un 5 alessio e la
squadra
esulta con lui allora il primo momento
ha cambiato che cosa alessio ha fatto di
quella palla e è valso un punto per la
sua squadra il secondo momento cambierà
quello che alessio farà nelle prossime
partite
questo non è un caso isolato il primo
allenatore di alessio lo fa spesso da
bordo vasca incita i ragazzi grida
spesso di farsi avanti e li supporta
quando li vedi indecisi o non sanno che
cosa fare
una volta dopo un allenamento
il primo allenatore si è avvicinato a
mio figlio gli ha messo una mano sulla
spalla e gli ha detto quando hai la
palla davanti alla porta ci devi provare
devi tirare
perché se tu non provi a tirare non
saprai mai se sarà in grado di farlo o
meno allora tutti i bravi allenatori
fanno così non è una cosa speciale
però bisogna trovarli bravi allenatori
questa che vedete nella slide e manuela
zanchi è un oro alle olimpiadi 2004 con
il setterosa adesso fa l'allenatrice
dice una cosa semplice quando chiede a
uno dei suoi ragazzi di scendere in
vasca
prima lo guarda negli occhi e gli dice
io credo in te io credo in te diventa
quasi una formula magica e cambia la
situazione
allora ma cosa c'entra tutto questo con
lo show in gap delle donne di cui stiamo
parlando oggi la percentuale di bambine
che fanno sport di squadra in italia è
bassissima e la situazione peggiora tra
l'adolescenza e 20 anni quando c'è una
caduta verticale delle ragazze che fanno
sport
se guardiamo poi ai numeri diventa quasi
imbarazzante sei bambini su 10 tra i 10
e tra i tre e dieci anni fanno sport di
squadra mentre cinque bambini su dieci
fanno sport individuali e spesso si
tratta di danza e di ginnastica
artistica perché è importante che le
bambini imparino a correre dietro una
palla in fondo anche negli sport
individuali l'allenatore incita sostiene
e promuove ma c'è una differenza ed è
una differenza basilare la differenza
sta nel fatto che nella danza e nella
ginnastica artistica
le bambine vengono spronati a alla
perfezione la perfezione del gesto del
movimento dell'espressione negli sport
di squadra invece
l'incitamento è a provarci
allora perché è importante una
differenza non da poco se andiamo avanti
a vedere quello che succede poi
crescendo gli studi ci dimostrano per
esempio che gli uomini hanno promozioni
e aumenti sulle prospettive future della
loro carriera
le donne invece molto spesso hanno
lavorano bene danno il massimo e
aspettano la promozione el aumento
perché credono che qualcuno possa
riconoscere il loro valore
quando ci riescono quindi avere quella
promozione quell'aumento ci riescono sui
risultati passati non sono le
prospettive future e sempre quando ci
riescono perché non è detto
allora un esempio concreto è la banca
d'italia
i test in banca d'italia erano fatti in
modo che le risposte non date venivano
calcolate come risposte sbagliate da
un'indagine interna hanno dimostrato che
questo tipo di valutazione penalizzava
fortemente le donne perché le donne
quando si trovano davanti a una domanda
a cui non sanno rispondere non ci
provano lasciano il foglio in bianco gli
uomini quando si trovano davanti a una
domanda a cui non sanno rispondere ci
provano e corrono anche il rischio di
azzeccarci allora in questo modo
venivano valorizzate le risposte tentate
degli uomini e venivano penalizzate
quelle non date delle donne
la banca d'italia ha cambiato i test e
ora sono diversi ed hanno chance a tutti
allora
stessa cosa accade in generale per tutti
i ruoli le promozioni i lavori anche qui
gli studi dimostrano che se le donne non
hanno il 100 per cento dei requisiti che
vengono richiesti non si fanno neanche
avanti agli uomini in genere basta un 50
per cento e ci provano
se non fosse così non si spiegherebbe
questa differenza abissale che c'è fra
il corso di studi e il mondo del lavoro
se noi andiamo a vedere il mondo dello
studio otto ragazze su dieci di solito
decidono di continuare il corso di studi
dopo il diploma 6 ragazzi su 10 fanno la
stessa cosa
quindi le ragazze partono in vantaggio
sono già di più ma poi durante la
carriera universitaria riescono anche a
ottenere risultati migliori voti
migliori finiscono più spesso in corso
hanno voti di laurea più alti e hanno
esperienze extra curriculari molto più
solide dei ragazzi
eppure il mondo del lavoro premia gli
uomini
se noi andiamo a vedere i dati a cinque
anni dalla laurea
ci sono molti più ragazzi laureati che
lavorano di quante non siano le ragazze
non solo i ragazzi molto più spesso
hanno un contratto a tempo indeterminato
mentre le ragazze no
e questa è una differenza che poi
continua anche in altri ambiti nel mondo
del lavoro come quello salariale
dopo cinque anni i laureati guadagnano
il 19 per cento in più delle laureate
voi direte dipende dal corso di studi
che uno fa dalla professione dalla
carriera
certo ma se noi prendiamo un laureato e
una laureata che hanno le stesse
competenze lo stesso ruolo all'interno
di un'azienda e le stesse mansioni
comunque sopravvive una differenza
salariale dopo cinque anni dalla laurea
di 150 euro e neanche a dirlo le donne
vengono maggiormente penalizzate dopo la
maternità
a quel punto a quella tensione verso la
perfezione
che ci portiamo avanti da quando siamo
piccoli si aggiunge l'inadeguatezza e il
senso di colpa per non poterci dedicare
in modo totalizzante alla nostra
professione
ci sentiamo in colpa in famiglia e ci
sentiamo in colpa sul lavoro un senso di
inadeguatezza che fa sì che facciamo
fatica alzare la mano ea proporci e lo
si vede lo si vede nelle aziende lo si
vede nella politica lo si vede nelle
imprese ai vertici delle imprese
italiane sono una manciata alle donne
che occupano posizioni apicali e vi
faccio anche un altro esempio quello
della politica uno dei più grandi
partiti italiani in questo momento sta
andando a congresso
se noi andiamo a vedere i candidati sono
sette uomini non c'è una donna che ha
alzato la mano e ha detto sono io la
persona giusta per questa situazione
neanche una
a me peraltro succede lo stesso nella
mia professione vi faccio un esempio
piccolissimo ma che vi dà la sensazione
di quello che voglio comunicarvi io
scrivo un'intervista intervistona
esperto di un certo tema il giorno dopo
ricevo un tot di messaggi e di
telefonate di altri uomini che mi dicono
io ho le competenze per dirtelo meglio
io ho l'esperienza per essere
interessante per approfondire quel tema
non succede mai dico mai che ci sia una
donna che mi manda un messaggio mi fa
una telefonata in cui mi dice io posso
essere la persona giusta da intervistare
allora può essere che le donne non
credano di avere le competenze può
essere anche che siano talmente
impegnate a lavorare sodo che magari non
hanno il tempo di fare quella telefonata
o di mandare quel messaggio oppure
pensano che lavorando bene noi
giornalisti prima o poi li scopriremo e
saremo noi a fare quella telefonata per
intervistarle il risultato però è che
sui giornali voi trovati tutti esperti
uomini con foto con le braccia
incrociate e pochissime donne e questo
non può essere non può essere
assolutamente soltanto
responsabilità dei giornalisti ci sono
però dei modelli femminili che stanno
emergendo e allora torno a parlare dello
sport questa che vedete nella fotografia
sara gama capitano della juventus e
capitana della nazionale di calcio
femminile che si è qualificata ai
mondiali del 2019 in francia dopo 19
anni di assenza della squadra italiana è
stata invitata a tenere un discorso al
quirinale per i 120 anni della figc e
nonostante l'evidente emozioni non le ha
mandate a dire ha detto che la storia
delle donne nel calcio italiano è molto
più recente non ha sicuramente 120 anni
e che le donne per raggiungere gli
stessi risultati degli uomini in questo
momento hanno bisogno di sostegno hanno
bisogno di investimenti hanno bisogno di
occasioni per poter crescere e magari
poter aspirare al professionismo perché
in italia le sportive che sia sara gama
o che sia federica pellegrini non sono
professioniste sono dilettanti
vuol dire che non hanno le stesse tutele
e non hanno gli stessi contratti dei
loro colleghi uomini e sara gama ha
rivendicato una strada che non è più
evitabile dimostrando doti da capitan a
non soltanto in campo ma anche fuori dal
campo di fronte alle istituzioni ha
rappresentato in quel discorso tutte
quelle giovani che oggi fanno sport e
sperano che lo sport possa diventare per
loro una professione e non si è tirata
indietro e chissà quante volte sarà
gamma dal bordo del campo sia sentita
gridare da qualcuno dal suo allenatore
da un sostenitore tira all'inizio del
mio intervento
gli ho parlato di mio figlio questa che
vedete nella foto è mia figlia alice
aveva meno di due anni veniva il campo
da basket prendeva la palla e stava lì
faceva fatica anche soltanto a stare in
piedi
guardava il canestro e lo sfidava
passava il tempo a tirare e chiaramente
a non riuscire a fare canestro è
cresciuta alice dicendo di voler il
voler fare basket e oggi è la più
giovane iscritta della sua società
sportiva ora li c'e tira canestro e lo
centra
e anche chi le grida tira da bordo campo
e quando cresci con qualcuno che ti
grida attira prima o poi quel tir a te
lo senti risuonare dentro e nei momenti
di crisi nei momenti di necessità riesce
a dirtelo da sola mi piacerebbe che
pensassimo quindi a gridare tira a tutte
le bambine e le giovani con cui abbiamo
a che fare tutti i giorni ma soprattutto
mi piacerebbe che ci ricordassimo di
quella bambina di poco più di un anno
che a quella palla enorme in mano guarda
il canestro e lo sfida perché quella
bambina
l'abbiamo dentro ognuna di noi e allora
forse nel momento in cui ce ne sarà
bisogno
sarebbe interessante e sarebbe opportuno
che ognuna di noi sapesse gridare a
quella bambina tira
[Applauso]